[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi racconto una storia da ragazzino
prendeva un treno che da castel gandolfo
dove sono nato e cresciuto mi portava a
roma e andavo in un negozio di musica
che sta in centro e vendeva strumenti
musicali cd vinili e spartiti entravo
nella camera degli spartiti e
cominciavano a sfogliare no tra i libri
con curioso cercavo tutte quelle parti
che da solo non è riuscito ad imparare
ad orecchio
erano tutti spartiti rock e succedeva
che poi da una parte in un angoletto e
prendevo un fogliettino di carta e una
penna e cominciavo a trascrivere a
memoria quello che mi ricordava quello
che avevo visto e letto su questi spazi
ti facevo questa cosa un po perché non
aveva una lira insomma tutti abbiamo
vissuto quel momento della nostra vita
nel quale avremmo voluto avere qualcosa
ma che però purtroppo non potevamo avere
quell età tra i 12 e 16 anni
succedeva che durante queste
trascrizioni probabilmente un po la
paura di essere sgamato
io come testi degli errori e quindi
quando tornava a casa le cose non mi
tornavano però la cosa interessante è
che da questi errori
poi si producevano delle interessanti
opportunità creative andavo da altre
parti
e questa cosa mi affascinava io l'ho
trovata anche utile in seguito il futuro
cito rodin amate in maniera appassionata
alla vostra missione perché non esiste
una più bella questa
questa frase ma quando mio padre in una
mail tanto tempo fa io penso che la
musica e suonare sia un'attività
terapeutica attività medicamentosa
succede che quando sono a casa a un
certo punto prendo la chitarra e
comincia a strimpellare così per il puro
piacere di farlo mi fa stare bene
se dovessi sedermi a un tavolino e
scrivere qualcosa
una musica una canzone come se fosse una
punizione mi sentirei un disgraziato le
idee mi vengono un po così per caso
preferirei piuttosto uscire e fare una
passeggiata magari
come uno dei miei scrittori preferiti
che robert walser uscire e fare una
passeggiata questa cosa mi piace oppure
andate al cinema leggere un libro
frequentare le persone a cui voglio bene
insomma diciamo che è un processo di
capitalizzazione degli stimoli che
ricevo dal mondo sotto più punti di
vista magari dai suoni dalle relazioni e
anche dalla natura che vanno a finire
tutte in una scatola una specie di
scatola che nella testa e se sono
fortunato aperta questa scatola magari
ci trovo un disco oppure una buona idea
un titolo per per una canzone oppure una
visione per un progetto nel peggiore dei
casi non ci trovo niente quello che ci
trovo lo prendo lo cestino solitamente
mi succede questo
quando quando pensa la chitarra pensa
uno strumento divertente pensa uno
strumento eccitante
è uno strumento immediato la chitarra è
diversa dal pianoforte il pianoforte
devi premere il tasto il tasto muove un
martelletto il martelletto va a toccare
la corda invece la chitarra la prendi la
tela mette in macchina e sta sempre con
te la chitarra non ti lascia mai solo la
musica in generale non ti lascia mai
solo e ho sempre cercato di vedere
questo strumento da punti di vista
diversi
o perlomeno diversi da quelli degli
altri
vi faccio un esempio da ragazzo
ragazzino tutti i miei amici compravano
un effetto per chitarra che si chiama di
lei
questo effetto reso celebre da di age
degli u2 tu suoni una nota e lui produce
delle ripetizioni col quale puoi fare
dei giochi ritmici affascinanti
divertenti e crea anche delle atmosfere
e dei fondali utili tuttavia io cercavo
di riprodurre questo tipo di suono a
mano senza senza avere questo questo
effetto mi piaceva l'idea di poterlo
fare da me la stessa cosa
l'ho provata con la musica africana di
cui sono un fan un ammiratore
quando ho ascoltato per la prima volta
la cora
ho cercato di imitarla limitarla con la
con la mia chitarra ecco l'idea di poter
imitare un suono uno strumento con un
altro strumento
credo che sia una bella opportunità
qualche giorno fa sono stato ad una
mostra in questa mostra un certo punto
c'erano dei video e c'era un video
interessante dove un docente parlava
alla sua classe si parlava di di
scultura e diceva non costruite delle
statue piuttosto costruite dei sassi
delle pietre e poi spiegava perché le
statue no e le pietre sì perché le
pietre le dobbiamo immaginare scagliate
nel vuoto ecco vi lascio con questa mia
pietra miliare per voi e spero che possa
solleticare la vostra creatività
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è
[Musica]
ebbene
[Applauso]
[Musica]